a concussion is a brain injury resulting
from a violent head impact or rapid head
acceleration deceleration
the brain is a soft and pliable organ
and requires physical protection from
the environment
the walls of the cranial cavity provide
a hard external shield from outside
impacts
inside the cranium the brain floats in
and is surrounded by cerebrospinal fluid
cerebrospinal fluid provides a
protective cushion as everyday movements
of the head gently jostle the brain
a violent impact or rapid acceleration
deceleration of the head can cause the
brain to rotate and strike the inside of
the skull
this injury compresses the brain and
sends shock waves Rippling away from the
point of impact
the impact Force stretches or tears
neuronal axons
resulting in a mild form of the
traumatic brain injury called diffuse
axonal shearing
this injury compromises normal brain
function because it interrupts
communication between neurons
physical symptoms of concussion include
headache
nausea
poor muscle coordination
dizziness
light sensitivity and blurred vision
ringing in the ears and loss of
consciousness
cognitive and emotional symptoms include
disorientation
confusion
amnesia
inability to focus and concentrate
irritability
and depression
treatment for concussion depends on the
severity and duration of symptoms mild
concussions require plenty of rest
increased fluids and close monitoring of
symptoms for 24 to 48 hours although
mild pain medication such as
acetaminophen or Ibuprofen may be
prescribed alcohol and illegal drugs
should be avoided
severe concussions require immediate
Professional Medical evaluation in many
cases steroids are used to decrease
swelling and inflammation in the brain a
CT scan or MRI of the brain may be
needed to rule out gross internal damage
or hemorrhages